Je veux dire, imaginez ce qu'il faudrait pour
matraquer quelqu'un aujourd'hui l'amour de la
guérison contrôlée de l'excitation la
discussion pour accumuler un cadavre,
comment pourriez-vous obtenir cela de l'
ordinaire récemment, je peux étouffer la
bile fabriquer de l'empathie lorsque nos
sujets ou au moins informatif  nous avons
décidé que personne n'a été dans la deuxième fois
j'essaie de te protéger ton attitude
va te mordre dans le cul nous
développons un modèle de comportement
qui ne te dédaignera pas tu es si jeune
vraiment dans la vie des gens nous devons savoir
exactement à quel point nous devons nous inquiéter de la
rage légale et avoir besoin de nous sentir désolés, ce n'est pas notre
travail de compatir avec ces gens,
c'est notre travail de les électrocuter ne peut pas
aimer tout ce que nous faisons, nous parlons à
Siri d'accord si tout cela va
fonctionner nous  besoin de parler un peu plus de guerre
tu veux des ennuis tu te mets dans la
boue avec le cochon non nous ne sommes pas le
FBI
comment pouvons-nous devancer les fous si nous ne savons pas à
quel point les choses sont folles
[Musique]